alright guys we've got David here we are
recording live at cut by Wolfgang Puck
if you have not been to one of these you
should come tons of fun
David thank you for coming thanks for
having me pop alright we got a lot to
come to cover so let's start first with
your background and then we can figure
out how you got into crypto yeah so I
grew up in southeast Michigan I went to
the University of Michigan and graduated
2012 went straight to Chicago for a year
really learned the real estate industry
worked for development company there
mostly focus on retail and then I
brought that brought that skill set back
to my family's office in the Detroit
area and we worked on a lot of
turnaround deals until around 16 16 17
when I got an interest in crypto if you
went to Michigan I'm assuming that
you're not a big Ohio State fan no not
not really alright we won't go there
so when you got into crypto was the
first time you ever heard about Bitcoin
blockchain crypto 2013 is when I first
heard about it I wasn't as active as I
am now in the space but I bought three
Bitcoin and put them in a safe held onto
them and it wasn't really until
aetherium came about until started
really getting much more involved with
the programmability of that blockchain
and the the opportunities that come from
that God and what was your initial
reaction when you first came across
crypto did you think everyone was crazy
no I mean I think I was skeptical just
like most people I didn't really
understand what the value was or why we
needed it or you know why would even
someone pay for a Bitcoin I think I had
the same similar reactions that most
people have when they first hear about
the tech got it and then maybe talk a
little bit about what you guys are doing
now I know that you guys just made a
couple of announcements and then we can
get into some of the nuances of it yeah
so total is focused on providing
exchange functionality for every defiant
decentralized financial application in
the world
so basically all of these great
entrepreneurs and businesses out there
are developing decentralized
applications whether it's a defy two
games two platforms and most of them
need or almost all of them need some way
for the participants to change one token
to another and that process requires
some sort of exchange functionality and
total provides that in one source all
right so a traditional exchange pretty
self-explanatory a buyer seller come
they meet they decide on a price and
they exchange whatever the asset is for
usually capital or currency what is the
difference between a centralized
exchange and a decentralized exchange
yeah that's a good question so that's
all I do is good questions on this
podcast yeah okay I'll try only good
answers so basically in a centralized
exchange which is the model that humans
have known for almost all of time you
you come to a centralized exchange and
you deposit your assets right you give
up possession your assets the first
thing you do and why do you do that
because you give it to an administrator
you need someone who's going to keep
track of all the stuff and make sure
that all the trades you make and all the
actions you take on that exchange go
through the problem with that is you're
putting your trust in that in that third
party in that administrator because they
have your assets yeah they they take
possession whether you know it's legal
or whether they you know some some
jurisdiction says that they need to take
your assets whatever it may be they have
possession which is worth a lot so in
our opinion the only real way to trade
crypto assets is through decentralized
exchanges and this takes out the need
for that administrative party that third
party and so without a middleman you can
trade directly with with your peers
using decentralized exchanges and smart
contracts so I get in a centralized
world where I take my assets I put it on
the exchange rather I deposit it and
there's an administrator that basically
has control or
custody of those assets and then when I
make trades they're helping to
facilitate that in a decentralized world
where do my assets it before I make the
trade yes so similarly if you're using a
centralized exchange but
where you even approach the exchange or
begin to participate you need to deposit
them from somewhere and when you're
doing that it's usually from your
possession from your what they call
wallet right well in a decentralized
exchange you actually visit the exchange
with your wallet so you actually in for
example if it's a total which is a venue
where you can you can do these exchanges
of assets you can go right to the
website on your browser right and if you
have a software wallet hooked up on your
browser like meta mask you can begin
trading directly from your possession
got it and then how does the
decentralized exchange match buy sell
orders compared to maybe a centralized
exchange yeah so that is the key right
there and that's where a lot of research
and development is going ok in the space
the this concept of party matching right
so there you need a way in a
decentralized exchange to take a buyer
and take a seller and since you don't
have that administrative third party
there needs to be some protocol or some
mechanism for people to follow in order
to be introduced to each other and
negotiate pricing and settle the trade
so all of that coated in decentralized
exchanges and the great thing about that
is that people can choose how they
implement this so you you have all sorts
of different choices you have air swap
you have Bank or you have Khyber you
have order book solutions like ether
Delta radar relay so however you feel
decentralized exchange is executed the
best you freely can choose what protocol
protocol utilize and it total we we hide
all that you can use all of those venues
in one one tool it's really what you're
doing is you're bundling every single
one of those protocols or many of those
protocols you just described into a
single interface and that interface is
where the value is to the end user
that's correct and what we've really
found is that it's not so much the
interface is it's the access so now
we've been selling the tech without
forcing people to come and use our
interface so wallets and portfolio
management software's they all want to
plug in our exchange functionality got
it so let's switch gears a little bit I
want to talk about what's actually
traded on these exchanges
in the kind of traditional centralized
world was called the incumbent financial
system you've got stocks you've got
currencies you've got bonds right
there's all kind of the traditional
assets in the crypto world what I'll
call the incumbent crypto world
centralized exchanges like the Gemini's
coin bases they've been fairly slow to
add all kinds of assets they've tried to
stick to you know large caps and and now
we're starting to see them leaked into
some of the little bit smaller ones
where do we end up let's work kind of
backwards from the future right so where
does this end up is it that I can go and
trade every all the currencies the
tokenized stocks the collectibles like
every digital asset in one single
exchange or do we get a fragmented world
where maybe all the crypto collectibles
are traded on a single exchange and then
all the token high stocks are traded on
another exchange and you get that
fragmentation yeah that's a really great
way to frame and I think that the that
you do get some fragmentation okay
I think you bifurcate the security style
financial of those type of instruments
and the new asset class okay and the
reason that I'm believe that so much is
that the laws today don't do not allow
you to trade other assets and securities
in the same mechanism so it's already
somewhat bifurcated in a way you're
saying you can't trade a known security
I'll say like a tokenize stocks I'm
somebody who has the issuer says this is
a security I'm going to treat like a
security on exchange commodities and
stocks it's very difficult to have one
platform and all of them mixed in from a
regulatory perspective yeah so once you
bifurcate those and when I say bifurcate
you have the the security is the
financial instruments and then you have
these utility tokens the tokens that
represent what and that's really what
the conversation is and we believe in
this new asset class maybe not so much
as it's been formulated by the entrance
to the space in 2017 but we're big
believers in tokens and utility tokens
we don't think that the highest and best
use or really what these tokens
represent has fully been been discovered
all right so
this is gonna be fun because I disagree
but I want you to convince me to believe
what you believe
my whole position on this is utility
tokens are definitely incentives right I
think we agree on that
we've had it Digital incentives for a
long time
streaks points badges etc this is a new
potentially more valuable or powerful
type of incentive but how is a user
going to manage ten twenty a hundred
different utility tokens across all the
different platforms they use or maybe
that's not the world you see in the
future yeah so with total you don't have
to manage all these things because we
exchange them right to the asset that
you want so that's one solution the
other part of it too is that I do
believe it is incentives but again it's
it's capturing value in a way that we
have not really understood it I'll give
you a couple examples and I can walk
through I go on Facebook and I like your
photo you won't write mine but you'll
like somebody's okay I like I like a
photo
whoever's photo that is right I've just
built their social equity their social
proof okay but in order for them to
monetize that they have to go find a
company right that wants to market to
the people who view their page take that
product stand in front of the camera go
hi I'm here and then have that company
pay them for how many times it makes no
sense it's like he's not really so if
there was a way to capture that value
right and immediately have you or have
me like this this photo and have that
person immediately take that social
equity and buy a cup of coffee at
Starbucks within seconds without having
to go through all the friction and
paying chase 2% twice to convert the
value well then you're gonna unlock a
lot of opportunity that we can't even
see or comprehend quite yet as a race or
as a it's funny you talked about this
Guzman
I forget the what was the company Klout
score I don't remember that we're
basically they tried to take all some
you know some formula and say how many
followers you have how much engagement
you have who are those followers etc and
they basically assigned it a score to it
and they said you know you've got 70 is
your score as Klout and mine is right
yeah right you've got
out that I had right yeah et cetera and
so really a lot of these ideas on the
utility tokens we've seen before in
terms of the directional idea now the
argument I think you're making is the
utility token itself actually provides a
much more powerful way to monetize and
incentivize people to do things correct
it's it's powerful incentives and it's
also powerful about capturing a value
that we could not put into any
instrument before this is a new
instrument that now represents value we
could not as a as a people as people
could understand so this is this is
completely new there's a new asset class
here for sure in my opinion would it be
fair to say that many of these utility
took it so example I always think of is
like AWS credits with Amazon right they
use it both as a way to pay so to get
access to computing power up to their
network etc but they also use it as an
incentive where they say hey I'll give
you $15,000 worth of AWS credits when
you start your company you start using
AWS switching cost is really high
now they got you in their ecosystem
exactly and they start doing it it's not
based on blockchain it's not
cryptographically secure but a lot of
the mechanisms and the underlying logic
that goes into how they use at AWS
credit is similar to utility token yes I
would say that airline miles would
represent the same thing reward system
reputation all sorts of I mean there's
guys outside of crypto that talk about
this stuff this isn't like you know
incentives aren't this like mind-blowing
thing that crypto created Bill Gross
even talks about it he says
pay-per-click was first the real
revolution is pay per action mm-hmm you
know and he doesn't really talk about
crypto all the time this is this is a
way to program isms to program
incentives that's what this technology
does do you think the incumbent
companies will who have these incentive
based programs right so the AWS is the
airline's etc does it make sense for
them to tokenize or put those systems on
a blockchain do they get advantages out
of that or do you think that they've got
what works they're using it they'll
continue down that path and it's new
things new incentives that people create
that
actually go on the blockchain no I think
I think eventually they do go on the
blockchain I think that the the the
incentive structure as you just went
through that you know wow that why they
have these points and stuff yep it
benefits the organization having the
points doesn't benefit the user it keeps
them in the ecosystem it you know it
benefits them by allowing putting on a
blockchain
that benefits the user now it allows
them to unlocks that value removes the
value from depending on American
Airlines to administrate that value for
them now they can take that value to
Iran and you know buy a piece of
clothing with an airline mile for the US
but they don't have to tell American
Airlines that they're doing that yep
so does this lead to this world of
gamification and incentives that we
could say that this like social credit
scoring that China is thinking about
right we're basically all of your
actions get assigned some kind of score
positive or negative kind of like an
uber type rating and if you fall below a
certain threshold you lose you know
quote-unquote access or rights to things
and if you are deemed a good citizen
right you get access to certain things
is that this does the end this doesn't
scare me this is great because really to
be honest you there should be multiple
scoring systems why do we have one
credit score that makes no sense why is
it that there's one Authority that says
where everybody's credit is it's like
ridiculous you should be able to go to
another network and say look this is
networks screwed up
they don't have my credit right and over
time it'll be proven if you're on five
networks and your credit sucks your
credit sucks if you're on you know five
networks and forums say you're a hundred
percent and one says you're a d1 you
know one screwed up so it's it's it's
it's more about opening and Lao increa
to decide all of these things I I you
know my personal belief is that free
markets and you could privatize every
government organization and a more
realistic into this you think that you
can privatize every government
organization hey every governor
organization every government service
what would be the hardest one to
privatize probably health care okay
why I
think it's such a there's a there's a
social aspect to it that's not economic
that gets tied into that I mean there's
a there's more than one of those but I'm
using healthcare as that example I'll
give you a good example
we just took public transportation and
we privatized it as a people how because
uber and the uber ization whether it's
uber itself as a company forget that I'm
using uber as an adjective we're we're
investors in lift over here we only talk
about I don't know ride-sharing what's
what's the word now that they is there
was well I was just in Texas and they
they had an abbreviation for it where I
stood I don't know what it is anymore
so the ride-sharing applications all
right so my point is is that that
created an economy for transportation
that didn't exist prior and it
completely unlocked value in areas of
this country that did not have
transportation for people you know to
move around I'm from Detroit
this is a great example we had no
transportation for people the suburbs
who grew up in the suburbs right so this
is a generation after all of the issues
we've had didn't want to go back down to
the city because there was no
transportation to take them there you're
gonna love this so my father who doesn't
listen to podcasts I think he literally
learned what a podcast was about a month
and a half ago said to be one time he
goes what what what did you just do on
your phone why the car came and I
explained it to him and he said I'll
never use that and this is like right
two years ago and I said why not he goes
I'm not waiting 20 minutes for that
thing to come pick me up that's how I
feel when people are like I'm not
waiting an hour for that transaction to
be confirmed it's like you're gonna wait
a week to get the check from the bank
like what is wrong with you well the the
spoiler to the story is he uses uber all
the time yeah I'm not trying to get him
on the lift train but he's still he's
still under that's fine
yeah because you have more lift currency
you know so let's talk about regulation
on a global basis for these
decentralized exchanges right so with
the decentralized exchange what you do
is you remove a lot of I think the the
aspects that are highly regulated in
traditional markets but they're still
going to be some level of regulation
how do you think about multiple
jurisdictions that are trying to all
look at a decentralized exchange and
figure out just what are the rules yeah
I mean I think it's a really big issue
because it creates a lot of friction you
know there's the the interoperability is
tough enough for the block chains the
interoperability of the jurisdictions
even worse and so I think that there
needs to be especially in the US this
hands-off approach obviously that's my
personal opinion but I see pregnant
realistically I see a lot of people
moving to these island nations and I
don't know how much in the long run that
really makes a difference eventually you
have to serve us customers that's what
the law is based on so maybe it's good
maybe it's good for testing in these
markets maybe that's how we make we make
progress I mean look at Facebook's
testing a stable coin in India so maybe
it's not so bad that there that were the
innovations coming offshore in order for
us to figure that out I'm highly biased
because I worked there if Facebook
launch is a stable coin in India it may
be one of the most impactful
applications of technology in our
lifetime true or false false why because
they're not innovating or you said
applications yeah basically if they do
that it could it has the chance to
disrupt a lot of the monetary issues in
India and it would be one of the first
times that a large technology company
went right head-to-head with a
government backed currency and said let
the people choose between a government
controlled option and a non government
controlled option it will be it will be
very interesting to see I definitely
think it'll be a big move and I also
think that it'll really have to do with
regulation more than the tech though I
mean I think right now right now India
is banned crypto right or banned I see
Oh they've gone back and forth the India
is interesting because they actually
took the path of the fight - which I
think is the most intelligent way you
don't go head-on with crypto and say
we're gonna ban ownership of it we're
gonna ban icos
all they said was - the legacy folks the
people who actually listen to the rules
and
think that whatever the regulator's say
is you know the gospel they said you
cannot work with any crypto companies
and so if you think of what from my
perspective the single point of failure
for crypto is still the dependence on
the legacy financial system which is
what they went right after how is that
different than the u.s. it's not if the
you if do you how would you if you're
the US government how would you and you
felt threatened by crypto Bitcoin
different blockchain applications what
would you do to try to stop or stall the
adoption in growth build a wall after
you built the wall what would you do
that's the only way to really keep
crypto out because like it comes through
with all the sensors there's no other
way to really keep it up they the
caravan of crypto enthusiasts no I mean
what would I by the way I just said I
just imagined all the characters from
Twitter like in a caravan and that's
really scary alright so what would you
though for real I mean I I mean it's all
it's an Internet infrastructure play
China's trying to do this every you know
governments I think I mean Russia's
tried to to block telegram
so blocking cryptographic applications
is not new
but I I would say if the if the I mean I
can't believe the US government whatever
that would be crazy to me
that they would try to destroy or try to
block it completely it seemed that seems
to say on American to me I I've tweeted
this before so I think he's comfortable
with me saying he said it Zuko
who's working on Z cash told me once he
said look a lot of people are worried
about the privacy coins and they think
the government's gonna say you know why
do you need a privacy coin if you don't
have anything to hide type argument and
he explained to me that which I didn't
know was when encryption first came on
the scene there was this huge debate
where the government basically said why
do you need encrypted communications and
data if you've got nothing to hide and
so there's this huge fight between the
government and people working on
encryption and eventually there was this
hearing in front of you know legislators
etc and he's like how funny is it that
today encryption is seen as a best
practice right it's right you're
communicating a non encrypted way it's
actually a bad thing right and so his
belief is look the privacy features on
tokens today well actually every single
token will have them at some point in
the future governments will get
comfortable with this stuff etc that's a
pretty big leap given where we are today
but there is some precedent with other
types of encryption or privacy
technology that it happened yeah I mean
my personal belief on the thing in terms
of viewing the the KYC and all of that I
think that that's needed for going from
your fiat currency to your crypto
once you're in crypto and you're in the
ecosystem going from crypto to crypto
doesn't seem like that's really needed
but I do think that there is a that I
don't believe in like no you know
complete anarchy no regulation I just
think that there it needs to be done in
a way that's gonna allow innovation in
this country specifically if regulators
get it wrong do people leave yes I think
that people do leave and I'm not sure
I'm not sure how please out if they you
know I'm not really sure I think they
leave in droves I I really do I mean if
there's a lot of people I talk to in
this industry and they do not live in
the United States they have no plans to
live the United States and some of it is
what I'll put under like the quality of
life right they just want to live
somewhere else I think it's better
warmer weather you know whatever their
kind of reasoning is but then there's a
lot of people who just say look I'm just
gonna sidestep completely all the
regulatory issues by living somewhere
else
yeah it doesn't again though once you
serve us customers it's you know that's
that that's the thing once you serve us
customers you have to play by us rules
we've done it total is we've decided
we're not going to play in any security
so we don't deal with securities you
can't buy any securities through our
software we are completely associated on
what's noted as virtual commodities got
it what's the most interesting virtual
commodity you've seen that's a that's a
good one what's the most interesting
they said that twice I know I'm on fire
didn't taught me it was interesting
virtual commodity Bitcoin I was just
gonna say that's the right answer good
job what's the second most all right I
mean I would say if they're going to
make it interesting we'll go with a
token
you know what I really believe in bat I
think that's gonna be one of these that
really makes it basically token that
makes it out of [ __ ] like they have this
platform and it's I usually explain to a
grave is an alternative to krump
it's a browser and its focus on privacy
it also has a native cryptocurrency
basic attention token bat and it that
would reward users reward venues for
their attention and venues reward users
for their attention and vice versa you
can pay them using the bat token it's an
ecosystem it's an economy based on this
token I think that it's going to
actually take hold with people who are
new to the space who have not really
used crypto before I think the product
stands first and that's similar how
we're doing in a total and our ethos but
they focused on this browser they've
disrupted the browser space right and
now the crypto aspect the incentive okay
to bring the thing full circle is built
in inherently into the model and so that
just by focusing on a problem that
people are having and developing a
product that improves their life right
and then using crypto as a way to run
that economy I mean they're doing it
right that's that's kind of it's
interesting because whenever there's new
technology can do one of two things with
it right you can either use it to build
something the world's never seen before
do something new with it or you can use
it to improve the old world and I think
a lot of people in crypto are focused on
building that new world things we've
never seen before and they're all
excited what that team did was they
actually improved an overworld right
they went to they built a browser we've
got plenty of browser options but they
incorporated new elements or kind of new
shiny advantageous elements that make
the old browser world much more
interesting to a lot of people are
interested in this world yeah I mean
that was that was all on purpose to you
know the purposely wanted to disrupt
Firefox that's that's what's happening
and I mean that's creative destruction
at its finest absolutely what's your
biggest worry in the crypto industry I
think it goes back to our last
conversation my bit my number one worry
is the US doesn't get it right
and that that's really my fear and my
the the second I think from the
technical side my fear is that the
tribalism in the space really continues
and we end up with a much longer battle
than it's needed to take down the real
enemy what what is the most likely way
that the u.s. gets it wrong is it around
regulation and like the security stuff
or is there something else no I think
they get in their own way I think it's
the same it's not different it's not
like a new story here yep you know they
end up in this situation and the guy
there their buddies want the licenses
and there's no way for them to make it
fit you can't this technology you can't
get your hands around right that's what
they're so used to their hands getting
their hands around making it okay okay
you had Goldman you you have this role
everyone has this role okay and it's
good that you can't do that with this
you can't grab this this is this is its
own life I hope no one from Goldman's
here but they got their own troubles man
they're the the 1mdb stuff is it's
pretty wild yeah and my other biggest
concern is it going back to the
tribalism and the fragmentation of the
market is the scaling for these
blockchains I mean we just had a delay
today you saw that you want to talk
about it and I mean I don't I didn't I
was busy all day so I just thought tweet
that we won't have this upgrade so the
etherium update that everyone was we
could say lightly excited about didn't
happen which in hindsight is like the
most crypto thing of all time right
like literally let's all get excited
about it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen it's gonna say
this you know it's gonna make it more
scalable and they didn't even get
launched it's not even that way didn't
work he just doesn't get launched
yeah I mean this is this is the thing
this is the new this is the fact that
we're in this era where this
organization right if Theory 'im is
there making all these decisions on the
fly there's no you know there's no
history for this stuff do you think that
is a disadvantage for most of these
utility tokens and all like all networks
slash coins and this is actually one of
the areas where Bitcoin because of the
slow development and because of the kind
of more methodical process actually has
an advantage or do you think it's just
those two things aren't really that core
people are making mistakes yeah I don't
think that when you say mistakes would
even by making mistakes well some would
argue that there wasn't enough planning
there wasn't enough kind of methodical
approach to implementing this and if
there had been perfect execution of it
we would have had it implemented today
yeah I think that there's truth to that
but I think that what you're talking
about these delays this all the the
disorganization or whatever you want to
call it it's a product of the fact that
these types of organizations or models
that come from crypto are not like the
old models right we're human and there's
there's a human element to the growth of
these organizations it there needs to be
consensus true consensus from the group
to change the protocols we have new
communities forking and happening and
you know like it just it's not the same
as a traditional model in terms of how
they evolve and how they develop so I'll
take this step further I was think about
this is the other day can you imagine
the reaction from the US government if
they went up to somebody and said shut
that off and the person's response was I
can't right right yeah I mean like like
if somebody's I hate shut off the
Bitcoin network and I can't you think
they know that you think that they can't
call mr. Bitcoin CEO and be like turn it
off bro it's over now so I will and I
said this quite a lot because I really
do believe it the US regulators
specifically have done a fantastic job
of toeing the line and what I mean by
that is they're aware of this stuff
they're really trying hard to get
educated they're only going after people
that are like the obvious scammers right
so people who are frauds who took money
and ran all that kind of stuff and
they've stayed away from like the
heavy-handed we're gonna pay in icos or
we're gonna ban this or you can't do
that and they may retro actively go
after people but I think that they have
allowed so you're Eurasian your opinion
is that the the fact that I cos were
billions of billions of dollars and now
that they're zero it's because that was
natural markets no no no I don't think
that it was all natural or do I think
that it was all
good behavior what I'm saying is if you
asked me should the regulator's ban all
of this before it happens
versus should they let it happen and
figure it out after the fact I actually
would lean towards the regulator's
weren't educated enough at the time and
they probably would say this to just say
we're gonna ban at all they didn't know
what it was they didn't hadn't had
enough time to do the work and so now
they're much more educated they're
likely to go back through that kind of
damage and say hey 40% of you guys you
guys are bad actors you should have done
that stuff you're in trouble the other
5060 percent do you think they really
care about the bad actors yes yes I
disagree I think that they come in and
if this is their opportunity to wait
just long enough okay to be the hero
okay and come in and save mom and pop
from crypto you know extravaganza
Godzilla and they over the next 30 years
they get to be looked at as the hero of
saving people and regulation is good so
by by enforcing that message for people
and by saying that the SEC actually does
something then they then they maybe
create a use for themselves in the
system do you think there's no use
there's absolutely no use for really
what would you so if they went away this
is interesting thought exercise if the
SEC and other regulators like them went
away how would we insure any sort of
compliance or sanity in the market it's
the same way we talked about all these
other private privatization you're gonna
have a private rating agencies gonna
emerge and they're gonna say this is
good this is good this is good this is
good and the only get away with lying
one time that's fair
along this lines is there the
possibility that someone builds a
quote/unquote decentralized regulatory
body and hands it to regulators and says
listen this is gonna do a better job
than you you should defer to this
decentralized organization that no one
controls yeah what do you think their
response is gonna be why I have an
opinion what do you think go fly a kite
all right before I wrap up I always do a
rapid-fire set of questions
what is the one regulation if you could
wave a magic wand and change or improve
that you would change or improve
taxation next question how how would you
change it remove it completely yeah I
mean if you don't need for government
services and government organizations
then why do you need taxation you think
there is zero need zero need every
private organization can pay you need
private security you'll you'll pay on
demand how would you pay for roads that
you use that are public property there
would be a private organization that
would obviously make some money for
administrating that process and you
would contribute if you wanted to drive
your car you hit some potholes I'm just
imagining like a road well you can go on
the cheaper road there's a lot more
there's a lot more potholes on that one
all right if the technology was there
and the car was able like if there so
here's my whole theory actually this is
pretty interesting so my whole theory
with blockchain and crypto is that we're
simply tokenizing every stock bond
currency and commodity in the world
because what it does is it empowers
machine to machine transactions it
empowers like all the automation etc and
so in that world there is a thing that
you could have right this is complete
theoretical when the car drives down the
road it knows how far you drove down the
road it knows what the price per mile or
price per foot or whatever is and it
actually pays for the usage of the road
rather than how much your income is and
we're gonna tax you based on it
certainly it's still a tax now you could
argue does that go yes not see yeah I'm
saying going to a public entity that's
what I was just saying but yeah I I
would say I would move taxes we get
blown away you said taxation that's
great no average so that buffed oh my
god oh alright if what's the most
important book you've ever read you were
quick on the taxation answer on the book
you can I don't one other to be honest I
don't read a lot of books I read a lot
of articles I did I did like the big
short the big short all right what's the
best article you've read recently that's
a good another good one I like my
favorite story and I'm three for three
yeah my favorite channel is the Atlantic
so I like with the media
my favorite medium I like reading their
stuff so I brought yeah okay what's the
most important company in crypto still
coinbase to me why because of the
influence they have over the retail user
if facebook launches something that hits
more users do they be do they replace
coinbase is the most important company
in crypto they compete for sure okay
that's fair so before I end and let you
ask me a question I was asked one non
crypto question probability that aliens
exist 99.9 percent how do you arrive at
99.9 percent and why is it not a hundred
because nothing is 100 percent that's
the only reason that's not true it's a
hundred percent true that you're sitting
next to me right now no it's not that's
pretty good all right Zoe why 99.9 in it
and nothing that's all there's to it do
you think that there's a shot that you
meet an alien before you die I would say
yes there's a shot I'd say that's a much
lower percentage all right the reason
why I asked that question is because I
always think like if I met what I do
yeah now can I ask you a question well
hold on the only thing that I would do
if I met anything is like you wanna go
grab a beer I don't know what else I
mean if you can speak to it and it can
hear you then probably the probably what
we'll do all right what's your one
question are you an alien come on you
got a better question that's it that's
my only question that's your question so
uh how could I know for sure so there's
there's one person who 100% I won't say
who it is but they always describe
people that they think are like the
outliers as they say that person is an
alien and he's in crypto and the last
time he said it I like pushed them on
what do mean he's an alien and he was
like well that guy kind of thinks
differently you know doesn't seem like
he came from where we came right I was
like there's a lot of [ __ ] aliens all
right cool thank you so much we are
holding people up from dinner so I
appreciate you coming we'll have to do
this again thank you for having me we
really appreciate it and everyone check
out total tio tle calm calm calm hundred
percent appreciate it